the firestorms began
[Music]
is
[Music]
have caused a global blackout of
communications and navigation systems
russia and the us claim the other is
responsible for the players of the act
russia are both being accused of
building armed
but for survival
[Music]
[Music]
awesome at the drop
good
the informant has arrived
[Music]
that briefcase is
usually i know what i'm risking my neck
for usually i don't explain myself
[ __ ]
there you are
bukowski
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
irish
you traitor
oh
how much did no pets pay you to [ __ ]
over your home country
my loyalty is with the refugees on this
boat
that includes you now
[Music]
irish all this better
i think you better take a look at
something
listen if you give us that case
that [ __ ] terrorist will start world
war three
that's what they always say pack
believe that [ __ ] if you want to
but i know what i'm fighting for
always big man
hey i got something for you
who's that
nobody
head back downstairs now
[Music]
put that back rob we don't get paid to
interfere i know but this is too big to
ignore
america's got an experimental weapon
that's about to fall out of the sky at
these coordinates in 36 hours
they're desperate to recover their daily
little secret
if russia gets it first
it could spark a war
[ __ ]
we can't let that maniac get his hands
on the coordinates
pakowski was right
ozzy's men will be here any second
he will stop at nothing to get what he
wants we have civilians on board we
don't have enough manpower i don't think
we have a choice
head straight into that store that's a
calgary fight sir
ah that's home field advantage
[ __ ]
i think they sensed the deals off
you have the conroe
are they taking this boat
irish the storm is gonna kill us
oh
[Music]
[Music]
that's how they see us
the world wants to forget we exist
give us
[Music]
you start this war
millions of notepads will die
in the crossfire
the price we pay
for a new world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
history will remember this irish and so
will i
only one way to stop this war
that's to get in the middle of it
put a call out to any notepad who will
listen
36 hours to noah
get ready
to fight
[Music]
you